in today's video we're going to talk
about references in microsoft excel
references are a key concept in excel
and whenever you use
excel you will almost always use
references
which is why it is so important to
understand them way but i will not only
show you how to work with references i
will show you a special view in excel
a special notation called r1c1 notation
that will really help you understand how
excel works
and things under the hood and at least
for me once i
first learned about this this was a
little revealing moment
and after which i understood axel much
better welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel firm learning my name
is heinrich and on this channel i want
to help you to become successful in the
first
years of your career but now without
further ado i have my laptop here in
front of me so let's
jump in and i will show you our axle
works
under the hood so here we are now in the
middle of excel and i just prepared now
a very basic simple example
let's now imagine we have different
companies or different subsidiaries of a
company
and they have had sales figures here for
the different quarter and now you want
to sum up these sales figures so i trust
almost all of you would be able to do
that there's different ways to do it i
guess you can just set up a basic
sum function like this you mark then the
range that you want to sum up
and then now here you have the sum of
these values included
now what most people will do now to
really get it down
until the very end is just to copy this
formula and then just
insert it here below in these fields and
now what you can see is that
the formula automatically adjusted here
now really to change the range to the
relative range down here and at least
when i
started to use excel while i had kind of
an intuitive understanding that you
could just kind of drag down formulas in
this way
i often struggle to really understand
how
exactly does it work because excellent
or somehow seems to recognize
that here there are some fields below as
well and then can adapt the range
automatically and now let's just
contrast that with just a made up little
other example
so let's imagine here you have workers
who work different shifts
and these are now hours they work in
this shift and now the worker one has
here these two shifts that you worked
and now of course if you now just copy
that down
excel is not able to directly recognize
that now actually the fields with data
switch and change right so here excel
doesn't give you the correct number that
you want and overall i just perceived
this to be rather random and probably
this was just due to my nativity in the
beginning but i just
didn't seem to figure out how exactly
these
changes in reference work and what
helped me really understand this on a
technical level
is to learn about the different
reference styles the different notations
that
excel uses and what we are all familiar
with is a so called
a1 notation and this means that the
columns are referenced in letters
right so a b c d e and so on and then
the rows are referenced in numbers
one two three four five and so on this
is called the
a1 notation but you can actually change
this reference style to something that
is called the r1c
notation are for rows and c for columns
and this makes
excel show you all the references both
for the rows and
for the columns with numbers while i
would not recommend you use this
alternative reference style on a daily
basis there are some things to learn
from it how
excel actually works under the hood so
let's just
check it out and to get there you need
to click here on file
and then on options and then in the
options menu you click on formulas
and then you need to check this check
box here for the
r1c1 reference style
and let's activate it and now if you
click here into the formulas you
directly
see that the reference styles are
somewhat different they don't look
like they looked before but now before
we jump into this
let me now explain to you on a
conceptual level how this
works what you need to understand is
that now the reference style
is always relative to the say that
you're currently in
so if you're not typing in a formula in
this cell and now you want to make a
reference to another formula you now
always need to define
both the rows and the column relative to
this one cell and how it works is
for the columns that columns to the
right of the reference cell
are referenced with a plus so this would
be
plus one plus two plus three plus 4
and so on and columns to the left
would be referenced with the minus so
this would be the column minus 1
minus 2 minus 3 minus 4 and so on
and the same thing now for the rows if
you go up this is actually a minus
reference so this would be
row minus one minus two minus three
you get the idea and if you go down this
is a plus so this will be the row plus
one
plus two plus three
and so on so let's make an example if
you now are in this cell
and you actually want to reference this
one here
this would be you start with the rows so
this would be the row one
two so minus two comma
and then the columns this would be now
the column one
two because it's two columns to the left
so minus two
as well and now another example if you
want to reference this field here
this would be in the rows one two three
four so plus
four and then one on the column because
it's one to the right so plus one so
this makes sense
now let's just see in practice how this
looks like and now just prepared here
just a sheet with some random ones just
to reference a few numbers
if we now would want to reference this
field here now it links you see that it
returns me a one
it's now referenced r minus one column
minus two
so here one up in the rows minus one and
then two to the left with the columns
and you see now that you always write
this first with the r and the later with
the c and then you put the numbers in
these rectangular brackets here
just ready to references now another
example would be
for instance this field now you see it's
one two three
four five rows and two columns to the
right and then this is what you get now
what happens if you actually reference
field in the same row in the same column
then you see
after the row you put nothing but then
it's only the columns -3 that you have
because it is indeed in the same row and
of course the same is true for the
columns so if you now
reference a field that is in the same
column you just specify the row and you
need to
specify nothing for the columns so this
is clear let's now jump back to our
example here
now i guess you can also more clearly
understand here the new references that
we see here
so here this field gives us again the
sum
and now the sum range is specified as rc
minus 4
so this would be here and then the end
point is rc minus 1
and this would be here so guess that
makes sense this is exactly what we saw
but now what happens if we copy this
down and maybe
you're already aware what happens
because now if we copy down this formula
it gives us the very same text
so the actual content of the cells here
does not
change at all and this is now the key to
understand now also this a1
reference style because what you have
here is a so-called relative reference
what this formula does it is always
looks at the current field
and then relative to this field it will
then specify the rows and the columns
because you defined the rows and the
columns
always relative to this field or cell
here and indeed
in the a1 style that we had before you
just
were not able to directly see that it
was a relative reference because
here then the values changed if we now
go back to the style if we now
deactivate the r121 reference method
here now again we see that actually here
it does
look like these references change more
or less randomly but it's not really the
case because below the hood axel
actually works here with these
relative references it always specifies
the range
relative to the starting position so now
back here in the rc reference method i
hope that you can see how this makes
sense
and now here as well now if we know that
this is how it works that it always
references the say it's your relative in
exactly this way then it is also
completely obvious why for instance in
this situation
excel is not automatically now shifting
it over but now of course what we do
need in some instances is not a relative
reference but an
absolute reference and of course excel
provides a reference style for this
absolute reference as way so let's now
look into another example which is
pretty similar you have now the
quarterly sage data from the companies
and then the sum but now you want to
forecast what these companies will make
in the next year and for that you have
set up here this basic growth factor so
you predict that the sales of these
companies will grow by 10
next year now of course what you can do
you take the previous usaids figures and
then you might apply it with
one plus this growth vector now to
provide you with this new figure so
basically increasing this figure by 10
now of course if you just copy this
formula down
you can directly see that this is not
giving you the results that you expected
and why is this the case well it's the
case because
due to this relative reference this
field on top of there it always moves
down
but of course what you want to do is you
want to always keep it fixed
you don't want this to be a relative
reference but an absolute reference and
yes you can do this with the rc notation
as well
because what you do is you type r and
then you directly type
in the number of the row or of the
column that you want to reference and
what you can now see is that once you
change to the rc reference style
here the letters actually switch to
numbers so also the columns
now don't have the letters a b c and so
on but they have numbers so now we
defined first the row
and this field here of course is in the
row number one and you can
directly see how this switches up and
now for the column
you put in here the column number three
and now it gives you here this column
number so now you see
you do not now define this anymore as
relative
to this field which is here always
indicated with these rectangular
brackets in the rc notation but you just
directly type in the number of the row
and of the column
just directly without this rectangular
bracket and now if you do this and if
you copy it over
you see this y this here now of course
this blue field here still moves
this red field here on top always stay
fixed
this is now how you include an absolute
reference and now of course you can also
do partial
absolute references if you here now move
to another example
what we now hear want to do is actually
we want to now project the growth rates
of the different quarters
independently so we want to predict that
q1 we grow with 5
q2 with 10 q3 with 15 q4 with 5 and so
on so now of course if you just would do
it in the same way that i
just told you so if you reference here
this with a relative field
and now you put one plus and now here
are one column 17
oh sorry column 18 which would be
exactly this field
if you do this then this will not give
you the correct result
because right here of course it now
gives you some numbers it always
keeps this five percent fixed but now of
course what is also not the solution
is just to highlight this as a relative
reference because if you now copy this
over
this also doesn't give you the right
value because not everything changes
right so while here in this first row it
looks good
once we now go one row down now of
course the references change as well and
now it gives you all these errors and
it's just not what you're supposed to do
so what you actually need to do here is
that for the rows
you do want to have an absolute
reference because you want the growth
factor always to be fixed here
in the first row but now for the columns
it's less clear right because for the
columns now you do
want a factor which is now here six
columns to the left because this is now
the factor that you want to keep
relative and flexible and if you now
include this and copy this down
now you see that it works correctly so
this one of course references here
and now this one of course even though
it's another row it still keeps the row
correct it moves
the growth factor across the columns
correctly but it keeps the row fixed so
in other words what you can do is you
can keep the row reference
absolute but the column reference
relative
and of course you can do it the other
way around this way
so let's now switch back to the a1
notation to looks like how you actually
do this
in the a1 notation this way so we now
deactivated the r1c1 reference style
and what you see here now is and this is
probably something that you might
already be familiar with here we have
now the dollar signs
in front of c1 or in front of this
growth factor
and again if we just take them out you
if you just copy them over without the
dollar sign as we also saw
earlier now of course this reference
becomes a relative references and it
moves but once you now click in here and
you insert the dollar signs and actually
you can do that in windows with the f4
key then it includes this absolute
reference and now if you copy this down
it keeps this fixed and of course you
can also do partial absolute references
in the a1
reference style as well so here now you
can directly see that the t
so the column reference this doesn't
have a dollar sign
and indeed if you here move around you
see that this
changes so here it's an r s t
u and so on but actually the row
reference the one this one has a dollar
sign
and it doesn't change independent of
which field you're in so here you can do
exactly this
you can now switch around and again if
you just toggle the f4
key several times you see that you can
toggle around these elements so here
this would be a completely relevant
reference
clicking once would give you the
complete absolute reference
once more it just fixes the row and once
more it just fixes the column
so that's it i trust that many of you
already knew about absolute references
with the dollar signs and probably had
an intuitive understanding of many of
these things but i hope that this video
really helped you
to really jot that down to really
understand on a more technical level
how this works and why the formulas and
references
changed the way they do in the a1
notation as always if you have any
questions leave me a comment below
in the comment section please if you
took any value at all out of this video
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also subscribe to my
channel to stay
up to date on all my content if you want
to see even more from me i also have an
instagram my instagram handle is firm
learning and later today i'm probably
going to release my very first
ig so stay tuned for that to see what
this is going to be all about in
addition to that i also have a mailing
list which has even more content
prepared for you guys
there's a sign up link for that mailing
list below in the video description it
was a pleasure for me again to do this
video i release new videos
every single saturday and sometimes even
bonus videos throughout the week
so looking forward to talking to you
again next saturday and until then great
weekend to all you guys